[inaudible].
Alright. Hey, what's going on? Welcome to my kitchen and as I mentioned,
I told you I was going to show you how to make a pie crust, right?
The fucking holidays coming up. Who's kidding? Who?
You didn't do shit with your life, right? You haven't done anything.
You're not bringing anything to the table. You don't have any kids.
Maybe you got busted for fucking drinking and driving.
You just don't fit in with your family that you got to do something right.
Then we'd go, you make a pie crust him. All right,
this is what you're going to need. You're going to need one of these,
a road pit, a fucking papers. They're staying in a pastry cloth,
like a board thing. I don't know what this is called. All right,
so maybe this is the graphic up right now, this thing, and he got,
you got two types of these things. He got this one. This is an old one.
That was one of the styles that I fucking hate doing.
That makes a lot of noise. This is, this was my grandmother's right?
I just took it from when she's on the weekend. I was just like,
grandma taking this right. You didn't want to eat. I'm just kidding.
She died and that's what I got. Um,
so anyways. Alright,
so two cups of flour and this is a,
this is the all purpose gold medal flour. It's not a
gluten free. Save the fucking with whatever the hell it is. It's like, look,
you're making a pie already. You know what I mean?
It's not going to be helpful today. Tell yourself you're going to go to the gym.
So there's two cups of this and you also put solid. So you just go like this.
You take the one cup dumping in like that. They should one cup.
Then I put the salt right over there. You getting there? Are you getting that?
You put the salt just like that. Dump it on.
Type of like that, right? Boom. See the done with that.
You take this thing here. You just doing what's going like this.
I don't know why you do this. Look at it. See how it's in there.
It looks a little different there, right?
[inaudible] yeah.
Naked worked with their products and they make sure you don't steal any.
All right? So at this point, I mean I'm a five year old could do this.
Everybody gets freaked out about papers, you know what I mean? Like, oh,
what's going to happen? What if I fuck it up? Who Cares? Nobody's watching it.
It's not like they're filming it. Um, all right, so this is, hey a,
this is a butter base cross. So you want eight ounces of it.
Every it's I kind of fucked up. I mentioned that. Well, it has it right here.
See what I make it nice and easy. All right. Eight tablespoons,
I should say dope. Two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight. It's a whole,
it's own goddamn stick. Um, so you want to have this shit cold.
You don't want to have it at room temperature because it's going to be too
mushy. So then you just take it like this. You've washed your hands of right.
Um, and you just cut it up like this,
cut it off. You drop it in there. You getting that Andrew,
for the people at home. You know what's funny somewhere,
I don't know why and I don't know who,
but somebody who's probably jerking off to this cause it is the internet.
Put the head butter in the fucking
wanting to see a balding redhead do.
This is why you want an 8.2 everybody makes 28 who did you?
Who'd you blow to get that thing?
And you don't have to suck any debt to get these. You just go to bed,
bath and beyond, right? The reason to sell yourself on the street and fight.
So now the problem is if you start going like this with it,
the buttons just going to get in here. It's going to be a pain in the ass.
So what I try to do is I just kind of used, he's only just,
I get everything covered in the flowering. I don't see that just like dad.
Now I want you to want to do what you want to do is just attack,
be tapped to. The butter's going to get stuck in this.
You start off tapping lightly, all right?
And then you gradually build an intensity.
This is essentially what all those women's magazines say.
Women like how you please them in bed. This is like the foreplay. Oh you are?
That is a beautiful dress. Oh yeah. How many brothers and sisters do you have?
Oh that's interesting. This is the hard part of doing a cooking show, Charlotte.
This is usually when like Rachel,
we're able to just tell some fucking stories cause it reminds me of when we were
like up in the cabins in Hampshire one time.
[inaudible] I
thinks she's on medication and that's sort of the consistency you're looking
for, their little coin y'all type of thing.
How fucking ridiculous is it that it makes it too much? You're going to get,
you're going to get a tough cluster.
This grease every real mother who still beats at children and crocs and stays at
home. Like women should say.
He goes to meet and Cresco and you just do the same thing to just cover a little
bit of flour so it doesn't stick to whatever the fuck this thing's called.
Stick handle with that a little bit. You know more Phil Castle,
less Sidney Crosby here. Right, by the way, are you guys were like, oh,
why did they have two half times in hockey? First of all,
the math doesn't make sense. That will be a third and a two third time. Okay,
it's an ass. Now you got into this, you've got that consistency going there.
You know it's just starting to come together. This is like Yo,
your pieces are shortening and butter, right? That's what you want to have.
Mostly mixed. So now they say four to five ounces.
I like to score and this is how I put in it.
What I do is I go like this and then I just,
you know whatever I put like like that much yet, whatever.
I don't even know what that is. Then you take it and you put this stuff on top.
Give it a little twist. I don't like the fucking kid in the mud puff. Alright,
same thing again. Here we go.
That was a really disgusting sound, wasn't there?
You got so it's not totally mixed. It's mostly mixed or whatever.
So now what you want to do, come over here or here?
Pastry cloth. So it doesn't stick. Let's take a little bit of flour like this.
PLOP it down.
Try to make like a little ball of it like that.
I'm pretty fucking good now for most people. You haven't fucked up already.
You haven't screwed the pooch.
This is where you separate the fucking something from the sump and this is where
it usually goes to shit. So you do just give it a little this, this way,
a little fucking that way.
Was there stuff on that, that stupid old. Same deal.
You stop going like this already. You start looking at that going, oh my God,
what's going to happen? Did I fuck it up? You did. All right.
You just keep calling like this and just trying to work at
like, you know you're trying to make like a circle. Here's your,
here's your applied this, you know, you know what you're doing.
You know circle is right, you're a, you're an adult. All right,
so now this is basically what you got and this looks like a big goddamn mess.
Doesn't it? Like like how the hell is that gonna fit into this, right?
And keep working in here, right? Oh, by the way,
I can't work 20 posts is the amount of people that are going to be giving me
shit. You should've done. All right.
You just take a little bit of this crap, right? You'd use it up. Yeah.
Now this thing is, this is an absolute shit show that does not. I mean,
you see it as a cross. You can see it. It's there not a fuck.
And you get this into that and to have it somewhat look like this,
look how perfect. There's this fucking bastard.
So that consistency is straight up.
Day is right here. This is the model for,
alright, so you just basically got one, two, three, Bam. Just like that.
Okay. You don't even think about it. You know,
it's like breaking up with somebody you don't want to be with. You.
Just sit down. What's wrong? I'm not happy and just stay in it.
What happened? It's not you, it's not me. It's just, it's right here.
It's just like this one, two, three, boom.
It's like that. Let me take this part over here.
Fucking bring it out that and bomb. Now you're gone.
Fucking third toe.
Now what you want to do is you want to push this down so it lines the,
uh, the pie plate here. And if you go like that, it's gonna rip.
So what you do is you lift this up like this. That's how you, I like that.
Oops. No one's ever going to know. All right? You push things down,
you start making things fit here.
Everything worked out. There you go.
There's your pie crust and a little bit of flour there. A little bit of flour,
nothing. And that's the, a fill is whatever the fuck you want to put in there.
You know, just start off with some, uh, some of your grandmother's recipes.
You know, if you think it's under seasoned or overseas and you know,
you make it an apple pie, not enough cinnamon.
Throw some more fucking cinnamon there to check it out. That's not bad.
That's not bad. That shit on anything. Tada. A,
you go, oh, fucking Philly pie crust for Christmas. Okay.
[inaudible].